I want you to think, just for a second about
breathing.
But don't just think about the fact that you
are breathing.
Think about all the variables that have to be just so in order to create the air -- and to make the air breathable.
So you need oxygen in the air but also if
the air was just oxygen, you would die.
The oxygen has to be mixed with nitrogen and
other gases,
and the whole concoction has to be at the right pressure and temperature in order to deliver
the amount of O2 that you need.
The air that you are breathing is a solution.
Also, not to belabor the point, but you are also kind of a solution as well, albeit a sentient one.
A solution, you'll recall back when we were
doing my dirty laundry,
is a mixture in which the particles of a solute
are dissolved in the particles of a solvent.
So, what's the solvent in air?
Well, whatever there's more of.
So, nitrogen is the solvent and oxygen, carbon dioxide, argon, and a bunch of other gases are dissolved in it.
All solutions have the qualities that they
do because of the same 3 properties;
Molecular Structure, Pressure,
and Temperature
These are the factors that effect a substances
solubility,
the amount of solute that will dissolve per
volume of solvent.
Whether we're talking about the air that we
breathe, the water that fish breathe,
the bubbles in Coca-Cola, or the toxin in
the tissues of the Japanese puffer fish,
what usually matters most about a solution
is how much solute is in it.
[Theme Music]
Often, in the lab we use placeholders like 'dilute' and 'concentrated' when talking about solutions.
But those are vague terms, and we should generally
be as precise as possible.
Here are a few ways to do that.
We could describe a solution by its molarity -- the number of moles of solute per liter of solution;
its molality -- the number of moles of solute
per kilogram of solvent; or its mass percent.
The mass percent of a solution is the mass of the solute divided by the mass of the solution all multiplied by 100.
So, when a can of your average soft drink has about 33 grams of sugar and a total mass of 355 grams:
divide the mass of the solute by the mass
of the whole thing times 100
and the mass percent of sugar in the solution
is 9.2%.
Easy-peasy there, but the more interesting
question here is ‘why?’
Why can you even dissolve so much sugar in a can of soda and what about all that carbon dioxide gas?
What’s happening here?
How does the stuff go in the stuff and where does it go and what’s actually happening at the molecular level?
Well, the first thing to keep in mind is that
not every solvent can dissolve every solute.
Gas molecules don’t interact that strongly, so gases pretty much always dissolve in each other.
But, liquid solvents have a ton of molecular
interaction.
So the structure of the individual molecules
determines whether a substance will dissolve
and how well it will dissolve.
Polarity is, of course, the biggest bit of
this.
For a substance to dissolve, it needs to interact
favorably with the solvent.
This only happens if they have similar polarities which allows them to form cool, in-solution structures,
spacing the solute particles out evenly.
Topic change! Say you’re on a first date,
at a sushi restaurant,
and you wanna be all cool and nonchalant and
“I’ll tangle if death if death wants me to.”
So you order the puffer fish, otherwise known
as Fugu.
Fugu contains a poison called tetrodotoxin,
and even in the hands of chefs who know what they’re doing, it makes your lips go numb just to taste a bit.
If the chef makes a mistake and you eat the
wrong part of the fish,
the tetrodotoxin will mess with your nervous system and cause paralysis, suffocation, maybe some death.
Why? Well, in part because of its polarity.
And yours.
Tetrodotoxin is covered on its surface with
polar alcohol and Amin groups.
So, it dissolves easily in polar solvents
like water.
And who’s made mostly of water?
So, if you watch Crash Course Biology, you
know all about sodium channels,
the tunnels on the outside of nerve cells
that allow them to communicate with each other.
Well, tetrodotoxin is really good at binding
to those channels,
messing up your nervous system, and killing
you.
Because it’s so polar, and your body’s
just one big aqueous solution,
tetrodotoxin has free reign to just jump on
every sodium pump you got.
Now, onto the next attribute that affects
solubility.
Let’s assume you’ve survived your first
course of your meal and you order a soda-pop.
To get all those bubbles that make carbonated
beverages so refreshing and tingly,
carbon dioxide must be dissolved in the water.
But how do you shove a gas into a liquid?
A gas gets dissolved into a solution the same
way David Bowie and Freddy Mercury collaborate.
[sings] Under pressure.
What? As previously noted, I am old!
It’s not just the pressure outside of the solvent, it’s the partial pressure of the solute.
Quick review: partial pressure is the portion of pressure caused by the gas we’re interested in.
In this case, carbon dioxide.
Gas molecules, as long as they have kinetic
energy, are going to want to escape the solution,
so they will be creating an upward pressure
on the surrounding gas.
In order to keep the CO2 dissolved,
the partial pressure of carbon dioxide and
the gas outside the solution has to be equal to,
or higher than the pressure of the carbon dioxide molecules pushing their way out of the solution.
That’s why soda bottles are nice and taut
when you squeeze them.
That little bit of gas up there is pressurized
carbon dioxide.
And, also why, when you open the can a huge rush of carbon dioxide molecules bubble out of the soda.
Because the normal partial pressure of CO2 in the atmosphere isn’t enough to keep it from escaping.
So, to get the carbon dioxide in there,
all you need to do is dramatically increase
the pressure of CO2 outside the liquid.
And this is what’s done in soda manufacturing
plants.
In fact, if you have a SodaStream, you can
do it right in your own home.
Now it’s easy to calculate this change in
pressure thanks to William Henry,
a friend of John Dalton of Dalton’s Law
of Partial Pressures.
According to Henry’s Law, the concentration of a dissolved gas equals the partial pressure above the solution
multiplied by a constant that expresses the
solubility of the gas in that solution.
And we can use Henry’s Law to figure out how much carbon dioxide is dissolved in our can of soda.
The pressure of CO2 in a can is 5.0 atmospheres and you can look up the solubility of CO2 in an aqueous solution.
3.4 times 10 to the negative 2 moles per liter
atmosphere.
So the concentration of dissolved CO2 in 0.17
moles per liter.
Now, there are 355 milliliters or 0.355 liters
of cola in a can.
How much volume would that CO2 take up at
normal atmospheric conditions?
Whip out your trusty ideal gas law and we
find that atmospheric pressure and 298 kelvins,
or room temperature,
0.060 moles of carbon dioxide will expand
to about 1 and a half liters.
That’s a lot of burps, something else to
keep in mind on date night.
Finally, in addition to polarity an pressure, it’s temperature that affects solubility in the most complicated,
and therefore interesting ways.
When we’re dealing with solid solutes and
liquid solvents,
their total solubility generally goes up as
temperature increases.
This is a fact that you already know if you’ve tried to put a bunch of sugar into your iced coffee.
The solubility of gases, on the other hand,
is the exact opposite
because colder molecules have less kinetic energy and are less likely to escape the surface of the liquid.
So, the upward pressure they exert is lower
than it would be in a hot liquid.
That’s why it’s safer and cleaner to open a can of soda-pop when it’s cold rather than when it’s hot.
While this phenomenon might result in a bit
of mess in your house,
it’s a much bigger deal for fish, who need
oxygen dissolved in water to, like, breathe.
At 4 degrees Celsius the solubility of oxygen in water is about double that of what it is at 25 degrees Celsius.
Trout, here in Montana, are highly evolved
to that nice, oxygen rich water.
But summer heat waves can cause the amount
of oxygen in the water to drop dramatically,
and cold-water fish can get pretty unhappy.
Also, a little dead.
Fortunately for Fugu, it’s a tropical fish,
so it’s perfectly evolved for 25 degree water.
And unfortunately for all of us, that brings us the end of this episode of Crash Course Chemistry.
If you’ve been paying attention today you
learned:
that solutions can be described in terms of
molarity, molality, or mass percent;
that polar solvents tend to dissolve polar solutes, and nonpolar solvents tend to dissolve nonpolar solutes;
you also learned about Henry’s Law which
states that the concentration of dissolved gas
equals the partial pressure of that gas above
the solution multiplied by a constant;
and that there are a lot of burps in every
single can of coke.
This episode of Crash Course Chemistry was
written by Kim Krieger.
The script was edited by Blake de Pastino and myself, and our chemistry consultant was Edi Gonzalez.
It was filmed, edited, and directed by Nicholas
Jenkins.
Our script supervisor was Katherine Green
and our sound designer is Michael Aranda.
And, of course, our graphics team is Thought
Café.